[Music]
welcome to the first episode on the
baseline infrastructure quest if you're
a novice cloud developer looking for
some hands-on practice with GCPs core
infrastructure services do yourself a
favor and enroll in this quest as a
student you'll get practical experience
by taking labs that dive into cloud
storage computing engines like
kubernetes and key application services
like stack driver and deployment manager
by taking this quest you'll develop
invaluable skills that will apply to any
GCP project after you're done with all
the labs in this quest you'll get this
badge to recognize your achievement
you can add the badge to your social
media accounts and your resume to let
others know about your new skills the
way this playlist works is you watch a
short video like this one where I'll be
introducing you to a lab on quick labs
and give you a quick overview of what
you'll learn I'll also point you to
additional resources where you can find
more information on each topic once
you're done watching the episode you can
head on over to quick labs and do the
lab you can watch all the videos and
then do all the labs or you can work on
the labs and pop over to the videos to
find the additional resources this is
your quest and you can follow it however
you'd like you don't even need to do the
labs in order I'm excited to get started
so let's move on to our next episode and
our first lab in the quest cloud storage
QuickStart console
you